Un public, observait déjà Dewey, est formé
au travers de la discussion et du débat. Si nous devons questionner
la tyrannie des idées préconçues, et
éviter la doxa, le domaine de l'incontesté, alors
nous devons accepter de soumettre nos propres hypothèses
au débat et à la discussion. C'est dans cet état d'esprit
que j'ai rejoint une discussion sur l'un des
plus sensibles problèmes actuels : comment
mobiliser différentes formes de capital afin
de construire un État.
Enonçons clairement nos hypothèses : le capitalisme,
après 150 ans, est devenu acceptable, au même titre
que la démocratie. Si nous prenons le monde tel qu'il était en 1945, et
nous regardons sur la carte les économies capitalistes et
les systèmes démocratiques, ces pays étaient l'exception,
et non la norme. Toutefois, la question actuelle se porte à la fois
sur la forme du capitalisme et sur le type
de participation démocratique. Mais nous devons reconnaître
que la période contemporaine a vu la naissance d'un consensus rare
sur les hypothèses, et que ce consensus fournit la base
de l'action, puisque le consensus
nous permet d'agir. Et il est nécessaire, aussi
provisoire et fragile que puisse sembler le consensus,
d'être capable d'agir pour avancer.
Mais la majorité du monde ne bénéficie
ni du capitalisme ni de l'organisation démocratique. La plupart
des habitants du globe considère l'État comme une institution répressive,
une structure qui nie
leurs droits, la justice, au lieu de
de les garantir. En termes d'expérience du
capitalisme, il y a deux aspects que cette partie du
monde connaît. Tout d'abord, les industries extractives.
Les diamants de conflits, les émeraudes de contrebande, le bois, qui
ne bénéficient pas aux plus pauvres. Le deuxième élément est
l'assistance technique. Et l'assistance technique,
cela peut vous choquer, est actuellement la pire forme
de cette face sombre du monde développé envers
les pays en voie de développement. Des dizaines de milliards de dollars
sont supposées être dépensées pour la formation
avec des consultants touchant jusqu'à 1 500 dollars par jour, qui
sont incapables de penser de façon créative, ou
organique.
L'hypothèse suivante -- et j'exprime ma profonde
compassion envers les victimes des événements du 7 juillet 2005
et du 11 septembre -- est que nous ne vivons
pas dans trois mondes différents.
Nous vivons dans un seul monde. C'est simple à dire, mais
nous ne tirons pas les conséquences de ce
monde unique dans lequel nous vivons. Cela signifie
que si nous voulons avoir un monde unifié, celui-ci
ne peut être divisé en considérables poches d'exclusion, d'une part
et en zones d'inclusion, d'autre part. Nous devons désormais
en venir à réfléchir aux conditions de réalisation d'un monde
véritablement global, que ce soit en terme de droits,
de devoirs et de responsabilité qui
auraient une portée vraiment globale. Dans le cas contraire nous
allons manquer cette occasion unique dans l'histoire,
où il existe un consensus sur les formes actuelles
de la politique et de l'économie.
Quelle organisation choisir ? Nous
avons trois paramètres essentiels : l'économie, la société civile
et l'État. Je ne parlerai pas des deux premiers,
sauf pour souligner que la transposition aveugle
des hypothèses, d'un contexte à un autre, ne peut
qu'aboutir au désastre. L'économie, telle qu'elle est enseignée
dans les plus grandes universités, est quasiment inutile
dans mon contexte. Mon pays est dominé par le trafic
de drogue et la mafia. Les manuels d'économie ne
peuvent rien m'apprendre dans ce contexte, et j'ai très peu
de conseils, de qui que ce soit, en ce qui concerne la mise
en place d'une économie légale. La pauvreté de notre
savoir doit être la base de notre capacité
à agir, et non pas la transposition d'une structure
fondée sur une modélisation mathématique, pour laquelle
j'ai un énorme respect. Mes collègues de
Johns Hopkins sont parmi les meilleurs dans ce domaine.
Puis, au lieu de débattre à l'infini sur la
structure de l'État, pourquoi ne pas simplifier
et dire, quelles sont les fonctions essentielles
qu'un État, au XXIè siècle, doit assurer ?
Clare Lockhart et moi-même écrivons un livre à ce sujet,
et nous espérons en partager le contenu très largement avec --
et, enfin, il faudrait pouvoir créer un index pour
comparer dans quelle mesure ces fonctions,
sur lesquelles nous nous sommes mis d'accord,
sont assurées dans différents pays.
Quelles sont, ces fonctions ? Nous en proposons 10.
Il s'agit du monopole de la violence,
du contrôle administratif, de l'administration des finances
publiques, de l'investissement dans le capital humain, de l'octroi
de la citoyenneté, du financement des infrastructures,
de la gestion des actifs matériels et immatériels
de l'État par la régulation, la création du
marché, les accords internationaux -- emprunts publics
compris -- et enfin, le plus important, de l'État de droit.
Je n'irai pas plus en détails. J'espère que les questions m'en
donneront l'opportunité. C'est un objectif faisable,
simplement parce que contrairement à une croyance
répandue, je pense que nous savons comment
l'accomplir. Qui aurait pu imaginer,
en 1943 à Oxford, que l'Allemagne serait
unifiée ou démocratique ?
Mais les décideurs à Oxford avaient prévu
une Allemagne démocratique et ont planifié en conséquence.
De nombreux exemples similaires à celui-ci existent.
Désormais, afin de parvenir à ce but -- et ceci me
ramène à notre groupe -- nous devons repenser la notion de capital.
La composante la moins importante du capital,
dans ce projet est le capital financier -- l'argent. L'argent
n'est pas un capital dans la plupart des pays en développement.
Il n'est qu'une facilité de paiement. Et ceci parce qu'il manque
les formes institutionnelles, organisationnelles, et manageriales
pour en faire un capital. Et ce qui est nécessaire,
c'est la combinaison d'un capital physique, d'un capital
institutionnel, d'un capital humain -- la sécurité est également
fondamentale, bien sûr, tout comme l'information.
Le problème qui nous concerne ici, et
c'est un défi que j'aimerais vous poser,
est qu'encore une fois il faut 16 ans d'études dans vos
pays pour former une personne avec une licence.
Il en faut 20 pour former une personne avec un doctorat.
Le premier défi est de repenser, fondamentalement,
le problème du temps. Avons-nous besoin de reprendre
les modalités que nous avons héritées ? Nos systèmes
éducatifs proviennent du XIXe siècle. Que devons-nous
absolument faire pour nous ré-engager
dans un projet où la formation du capital
est rapide ? La majorité absolue de la population
mondiale a moins de 20 ans, et elle augmente
sans cesse. Il faut des façons différentes
d'approcher cette population. Des façons différentes de
l'affranchir, de lui donner des capacités.
C'est le premier élément.
Deuxièmement, vous trouvez des solutions, mais vous
n'engagez pas votre responsabilité globale. Vous êtes
restés à l'écart des problèmes de corruption. Vous ne
souhaitez que des environnements propres dans lesquels fonctionner.
Mais si vous ne réfléchissez pas aux problèmes de corruption,
qui le fera ? Vous demeurez loin des questions
de développement. Vous êtes de grands inventeurs, mais
vos inventions sont égoïstes. Elles ne sont que pour
votre usage immédiat. Le monde dans lequel j'agis utilise
des schémas de routes, de barrages, ou d'acheminement
d'électricité qui n'ont pas été revus depuis 60 ans.
Ce n'est pas juste. Il faut y réfléchir.
Mais ce dont nous avons particulièrement besoin
de votre part, c'est que votre imagination
soit amenée à se concentrer sur les problèmes liés
au fonctionnement des mèmes. Comme l'ont montré, depuis longtemps,
les recherches sur les paradigmes -- les travaux de Thomas Kuhn --
c'est à l'intersection des idées que de nouveaux développements
-- les réelles avancées -- se réalisent. Et j'espère que ce
groupe sera capable de réfléchir aux problèmes
de l'État, du développement, et du renforcement du pouvoir
de la majorité des populations pauvres, de cette façon.
Merci.
Chris Anderson : Donc, Ashraf, jusqu'à il y a peu vous
étiez le ministre des finances Afghan, un
pays qui se trouve actuellement au centre des préoccupations
mondiales. Le pays va-t-il s'en sortir ?
La démocratie va-t-elle se répandre ? Qu'est ce qui vous fait le plus peur ?
Ashraf Ghani : Ce qui me fait le plus peur, c'est -- c'est vous.
Votre manque d'engagement. (Rires) Vous me demandez,
vous savez que je donne toujours des réponses inattendues.
Mais, sérieusement, le premier problème est qu'il faut
considérer l'Afghanistan dans une perspective d'au moins
10 à 20 ans. De nos jours, la mondialisation accélère
la marche du monde. Le temps a été compressé. Et l'espace
n'existe plus pour la plupart des gens. Mais dans mon monde,
dans cet Afghanistan où je suis revenu après 23 ans,
l'espace s'est au contraire dilaté. Chaque infrastructure
imaginable a été détruite. J'ai parcouru --
voyagé -- un chemin entre deux villes qui prenait auparavant
3 heures et en prend maintenant 12. Lorsque nous sommes
dans cette échelle, il faut simplement reconnaître
les caractéristiques de l'infrastructure --
il faut 6 ans pour fournir de l'infrastructure. Dans
notre monde. Toutes sortes de choses essentielles comme celle-ci.
Mais c'est la modalité de l'attention, ou "ce qui se produit
aujourd'hui, et ce que se produit demain".
Le deuxième problème concerne le fait que mon pays a été
soumis a l'une des plus immense et brutale forme d'exercice
du pouvoir -- nous avons été occupés par l'Armée Rouge,
forte de 110,000 hommes, pendant 10 ans. C'était terrorisant.
Le ciel. Chaque, je dis bien chaque, Afghan craint
le ciel. Nous sommes bombardés. Nous ne
pouvons plus vivre. Et il y a des dizaines de milliers de personnes
entrainées aux techniques terroristes. De tous côtés.
Les États-Unis, la Grande-Bretagne, ont coopéré,
par exemple, avec les services secrets égyptiens pour
former des milliers de personne à la guerilla urbaine
et aux techniques terroristes. Comment faire exploser une bombe,
comment transformer un vélo, un âne, un cheval de trait,
n'importe quoi, en instrument de terreur. Les Russes ont fait de même.
Donc, quand la violence surgit dans un pays comme
l'Afghanistan, c'est en raison de cet héritage. Mais nous
devons aussi comprendre que nous avons été incroyablement
chanceux. Je veux dire, je ne peux vraiment croire la chance
que j'ai de me trouver ici, devant vous, à parler.
Lorsque j'ai accepté le poste de Ministre des Finances, j'ai pensé
que mes chances de survivre plus de 3 ans
ne dépassaient pas 5%. C'étaient les risques.
L'enjeu était à la hauteur.
Je pense que nous pouvons y arriver, et ceci
grâce à la population. Pour l'illustrer,
je vous donne une statistique. 91% des hommes
en Afghanistan, 86% des femmes, écoutent au moins
trois stations de radio par jour. Si l'on compare
ce fait à leur discours, à la sophistication de leur
connaissance du monde, je pense que -- j'ose même
affirmer qu'ils sont bien plus sophistiqués que les
citoyens américains ruraux sortant de l'université, et que
la majorité des Européens. Parce que le monde les intéresse.
Et quelle est leur principale préoccupation ?
L'abandon. Les Afghans sont devenus profondément
internationalistes.
Vous savez, lorsque je suis revenu en Décembre 2001, je
n'avais absolument aucun désir de travailler avec le gouvernement
Afghan. Parce que j'avais vécu en tant que nationaliste.
Et je leur ai dit -- mon peuple, avec les Américains ici,
le -- séparés. Oui, je suis conseiller pour les
Nations Unies. J'ai traversé 10 provinces
Afghanes très rapidement. Et tout le monde me répétait,
-- c'était un monde différent. Vous savez,
ils s'engagent -- ils voient l'engagement, l'engagement
international, comme une condition nécessaire au futur
du peuple. Et l'aspect qui inquiète le plus
le peuple Afghan est -- Clare
Lockhart est ici, elle -- je vais donc vous répéter
une discussion qu'elle a eu avec une femme illettrée
du Nord de l'Afghanistan. Et cette femme lui a dit qu'elle
ne s'inquiétait pas d'avoir ou non à manger sur sa table.
Elle s'inquiétait de savoir s'il y avait un plan
pour le futur du pays. Savoir si ses enfants pourraient ou non
avoir une vie réellement différente.
Ces discussions me donnent espoir.
CA : Comment le gouvernement afghan va-t-il
fournir des moyens de subsistance alternatifs
aux nombreuses personnes qui vivent du trafic de drogue ?
AG : Bien, la première chose, c'est, au lieu d'envoyer
des milliards de dollars en programmes d'éradication
et en entreprises de sécurité, ils devraient envoyer
cette centaine de milliards de dollars aux 50
entreprises les plus innovantes dans le monde pour
les inciter à créer un million d'emplois. La clé de
la suppression de la drogue, c'est l'emploi. Il y a un fait
très peu connu : les pays qui ont un revenu moyen légal
par tête de 1000 dollars
ne produisent pas de drogue.
Le deuxième levier, c'est le textile. La commerce est la solution, pas l'aide.
Les États-Unis et l'Europe devraient supprimer les droits
de douane pour l'Afghanistan. Le textile est une industrie très mobile.
Si vous souhaitez que nous puissions nous mesurer à la Chine et
attirer des investissements, nous pourrions certainement attirer entre
4 et 6 milliards de dollars assez facilement avec l'industrie textile,
si les tarifs douaniers étaient supprimés. Cela créerait le type
d'emploi dont nous avons besoin. La culture du coton ne peut pas
lutter avec celle de l'opium. Mais la fabrication d'un T-shirt, elle, le peut.
C'est la chaîne de valeur. Et, aussi, l'Afghan ordinaire
est fatigué d'entendre parler de micro-crédit.
C'est important, bien sûr. Mais les hommes et femmes ordinaires qui
s'engagent dans la micro-production veulent un accès global au marché.
Ils ne veulent pas vendre dans les bazars
pour touristes, vous savez, et
vendre toujours la même chemise brodée. Nous voulons
un partenariat avec les entreprises de design en Italie.
Oui, nous avons les meilleurs brodeurs dans le monde !
Pourquoi ne pouvons-nous pas recréer ce qui s'est produit
en Italie du Nord ? Avec le système de production à domicile ?
Je pense qu'économiquement la question cruciale
est de maintenant tout penser en détails.
Et je veux ajouter que l'aide ne fonctionne pas.
Le système d'aide est cassé. Le système d'aide
n'a pas de savoir, de vision, ni de capacité.
Je suis pour bien sûr -- après tout j'ai récolté
beaucoup de fonds -- oui, pour être exact, j'ai réussi
à persuader les États de donner à l'Afghanistan
27,5 milliards de dollars. Ils ne voulaient pas nous donner
cet argent.
CA : Et le système n'a pas fonctionné ?
AG : Non. Non. Ce n'est pas que ce n'a pas fonctionné. C'est que,
dans mon opinion, un dollar d'investissement privé, équivaut
au moins à 20 dollars d'aide. En termes de
dynamique créée. Deuxièmement, un dollar d'aide peut correspondre
à 10 cents, 20 cents,
ou 4 dollars. Cela
dépend de la forme de l'aide, des degrés de
conditionnalité qui sont attachés à l'aide fournie -- vous savez que
le système de l'aide a été construit, au départ, pour bénéficier
aux entrepreneurs des pays développés, et non pas pour générer
de la croissance dans les pays pauvres. Et ceci
constitue, encore, une de ces idées préconçues,
que nous avons héritées des gouvernements.
On pourrait penser que le gouvernement américain
n'imaginerait pas subventionner ses entreprises
fonctionnant dans les pays en voie de développement.
Mais ils le font. Il y a tout le poids historique
vis-à-vis de l'aide qui doit aujourd'hui
être réexaminé. Si notre but est de parvenir à la construction
d'États qui peuvent se prendre en charge,
-- et je fais cette proposition d'égal à égal -- je tiens
à ce que vous sachiez que je suis très sévère avec mes homologues,
et l'aide doit s'achever dans chaque pays sous une période définie.
Et il aura des progrès chaque année.
Que ce soit sur le revenu domestique, ou sur la génération d'une
économie. A moins que ce type d'entente ne soit
concrétisée, vous ne pourrez être capable de
maintenir le consensus.